[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem samstag die vom sport hat norbert
könig und das sind die themen von heute
rufe nach gezielteren hilfen in der
debatte um ein drittes entlastungspaket
rücken geringverdiener in den fokus
rekordhitze in china große teile des
landes erleben den heißesten und
trockensten sommer seit beginn der
aufzeichnungen
und ausgezeichnet anke engelke diane
mädel und katrin eigendorf erhalten den
grimme preis
keiner werde alleingelassen weitere
entlastungen würden in wenigen tagen auf
den weg gebracht an diesen ankündigungen
muss sich die bundesregierung messen
lassen nicht nur kommunen und kirchen
fordern dass nicht mehr alle profitieren
sondern vor allem menschen mit niedrigen
und mittleren einkommen
britta buchholz über den stand der
diskussion der bundeskanzler kommt zum
wahlkampfauftakt nach niedersachsen
dabei hat er allerlei versprechungen für
das nächste entlastungspaket schon jetzt
beteuert scholz das wohngeld auszuweiten
und noch mehr natürlich ist klar dass
wir diejenigen die nicht von jedem
hilfspaket komplett erfasst werden auch
unbedingt noch berücksichtigen müssen
also rentnern rentner zb und diejenigen
die studierenden und es wird auch
unterstützung geben müssen indem wir
steuerliche entlastungen machen auch der
cdu parteichef ist im wahlkampfmodus er
kritisiert pauschale einmalzahlung sie
waren teil des letzten entlastungspaket
was soll das eigentlich dass wir hier
für 42 millionen menschen 300 euro
pauschal bezahlen ich hätte es mir
gewünscht dass nicht 300 euro für alle
sondern 1000 euro für diejenigen die es
am bittersten nötig haben aus
öffentlichen kassen bezahlt werden nun
gibt es viele wünsche an die ampel der
ig metall chef fordert einen preis
deckel für gas und strom der verdi chef
fordert eine 500 euro energie pauschale
doch all das kostet wirtschafts kenner
warnen davor den staat zu sehr zu
fordern der staat trägt ja im grunde
seit zweieinhalb jahren
wirtschaftsgeschehen in der pandemie war
das sinnvoll wir müssen anfangen da
aufzupassen und darum geht es jetzt also
jedenfalls mal auch darum die
energiekosten dies nun steigen nicht
komplett vom staat übernehmen zu lassen
wir müssen darauf als bürger reagieren
uns anpassen wenn der staat alle strom
aller heizkosten steigerungen übernehmen
würde würde er definitiv sich
überfordern oder wenn er das auf pump
macht würde eben die lasten in die
zukunft welt sind auch dass es nicht
vorstellbar noch wird alles diskutiert
auch die finanzierung in den nächsten
wochen soll das neue paket geschnürt
werden
wie wichtig die entlastungen für viele
sein dürften zeigt ein blick auf die
preise seit beginn des ukraine krieges
gehen sie deutlich nach oben die
inflation lag zuletzt bei 75 prozent
diesel etwa kostete im juli trotz tank
rabatt rund 40 prozent mehr butter
verteuerte sich um fast 48 prozent
mitunter offenbart sich die
preiserhöhung allerdings erst beim
genauen hinschauen berichtet martin
niesen
wenn erkennbar alles teurer wird nennt
man das inflation für versteckte
preissteigerungen gibt es das wort
trinkflaschen also weniger ware zum
gleichen preis haribo etwa takt statt
200 nur noch 175 gramm gummibärchen in
die tüte bei gleichbleibender
preisempfehlung ein quasi inflationärer
trick kritisieren die
verbraucherzentralen
wir haben starken anstieg anmeldungen
die liegen ungefähr beim doppelten
dreifachen was sonst in diesem zeitraum
haben also jetzt die erste welle die
jetzt uns erreicht haribo verweist auf
gestiegene produktions verpackungs und
energiekosten und dass die beutel
sichtbar verkleinert wurden so sei die
reduktion der füllmenge für
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher klar
erkennbar das können wir nicht ganz
nachvollziehen weil ja in im supermarkt
in der regel nur das neue produkt
vorhanden ist und nicht das alte denn
tatsächlich erkennbar sind die
veränderten packungsgrößen meist nur im
direkten vergleich auf die
verbraucherinnen käme da einiges zu
glauben experten
wir sind am anfang ich am höhepunkt der
entwicklung ich kann mir sogar
vorstellen kleinere verpackungsgrößen
jetzt geschafft worden sind sogar
standard für eine gewisse zeit werden da
ich davon ausgehe dass die rede die
höheren kosten leider noch einige jahre
anhalten werden für die konsumentinnen
bedeutet das also augen auf beim einkauf
damit sie bei ihren lieblingsprodukten
zu hause keine unliebsamen
überraschungen erleben
noch bis mittwoch geht das neun euro
ticket heute gab es bundesweit
demonstrationen für eine verlängerung
auch in mainz stand die aktion unter dem
motto 9 euro ticket weiterfahren ein
bündnis von umweltgruppen
parteiorganisationen und berufspendlern
forderte einen umfassenden ausbau des
öffentlichen nahverkehrs in hamburg gab
es nochmal gedränge auf den bahnsteigen
viele nutzen das letzte wochenende mit
dem neuen euro ticket zu einem kurztrip
wir blicken auch in die ukraine auf die
folgen des krieges der auch die
gläubigen trend denn in der ukraine gibt
es zwei große orthodoxe kirchen die
ukrainische und die russische geführt
vom moskauer patriarchen kirill der
stützt seit langem putins regime und so
wenden sich immer mehr christen in der
ukraine von der russisch-orthodoxen
kirche ab hannah hebestreit berichtet
kiews metropolit trapping co hat eine
mission er möchte möglichst viele
gemeinden für die ukrainisch orthodoxe
kirche gewinnen im ort motiven und wird
von im team übernimmt er deshalb selbst
die gedenkzeremonie für die getötete
familie von ländern die russischen
besatzer hatten im märz ihre eltern und
dem bruder gefoltert getötet und
verscharrt
meine familie meine
welt zerstört und
unsere leben zerbrochen in lotte sheen
ist der metropolit hochwillkommen als
die russen den ort besetzten verschwand
der alte priester mit seinen nachfolger
wollen sie sich von der
russisch-orthodoxen kirche los
das ganze dorf hat darüber beraten und
wir haben entschieden ihr nicht
russisches mehr haben zum
und unmenschliche aggression war der
letzte anstoß für uns niemand hatte mir
zweifel dass es richtig ist zur
ukrainischen kirche zunächst
mehr als 500 orthodoxe kirchen gemeinden
haben sich seit kriegsbeginn bereits für
die ukrainische orthodoxie entschieden
russlands kirchen hier haben versteckt
und auch ganz offen die menschen in der
ukraine beeinflusst und auch die
invasion gerecht kritisierte breuer
ukrainisch orthodoxe stadt russisch
orthodox russlands einfluss auf die
gläubigen in der ukraine schwindet
im vatikan hat eine mit spannung
erwartete kardinals versammlung begonnen
am nachmittag ernannte papst franziskus
20 neue kardinäle darunter würdenträger
aus ost timor der mongolei und indien
damit setzt der papst verstärkt auf die
wachsende kirche asiens die kardinäle
sind sein wichtigstes beratergremium
ihre auswahl bestimmt den kurs der
katholischen kirche
diesen sommer flüchten wieder deutlich
mehr menschen über das mittelmeer nach
europa seit donnerstag hat die private
hilfsorganisation sos méditerranée
350 migranten aus seenot gerettet
am morgen nahm die besatzung der ocean
waking malta dutzende menschen von einem
überfüllten holzboot an bord darunter
auch ein baby die fluchtroute über das
mittelmeer gilt als eine der
gefährlichsten weltweit
rekordhitze und viel zu wenig regen das
trifft gerade nicht nur europa in china
ist es sogar der trockenste und heißeste
sommer seit beginn der aufzeichnungen
der drittgrößte fluss der welt der
jangtse führt deutlich weniger wasser
normalerweise kann in solchen
dürreperioden der pro jahr sie den
mangel ausgleichen weil er in
regenzeiten wasser speichert doch nach
mehr als 50 tagen ohne regen sieht der
see so aus miriam stein aber dort
es ist eine insel die keine insel mehr
ist zu dieser jahreszeit sollte sie
eigentlich eher so aussehen
seit wochen gibt es in teilen china ist
eine dürre und hitzewelle
es soll der heißeste und trockenste
sommer seien seit beginn der
aufzeichnungen die folgen die lassen
sich hier ablesen das ist eigentlich der
größte süßwassersee des landes aber hier
wo wir stehen ist er nicht mehr erst
mich auf ein viertel seiner eigentlichen
größe geschrumpft das hier mal wasser
war dafür gibt es noch spuren der boden
ist nicht schlammig sondern hart seit
fast 50 tagen hat es nicht mehr geregnet
die satellitenbilder zeigen wie der see
vor einem jahr aussah und wie klein die
fläche heute ist das ist das was übrig
ist vom plan sehe nur noch in der mitte
ist das wasser tief genug für die
frachtschiffe die anwohner befürchten
dass es in den kommenden monaten sowieso
nicht viel zu transportieren gibt und
dann so trocken wie der see sind auch
die felder die provinz guangxi im
südosten chinas ist eine der wichtigsten
für reisanbau die angreifer kann sich
nicht erinnern dass es schon einmal so
lange so trocken war wir leben von
diesen feldern wenn wir nichts ernten
haben wir nichts zu essen
in ihrem dorf nutzen sie das wasser das
aus den bergen kommt es ist ein knappes
gut ich trete in haan nur ein bisschen
auf sie fängt das wasser auf um es ein
zweites mal zu benutzen zum beispiel auf
dem gemüse fällt das auch vertrocknet
ist sie rührt damit dünner an in der
hoffnung dass bald regen kommt wenn
nicht ist ihre komplette ernte verloren
nach einem brandanschlag auf ein
wohnheim für geflüchtete in leipzig
verstärkt die polizei den schutz aller
asylbewerber unterkünfte in sachsen es
sei ein alarmzeichen dass solche
menschenverachtende straftaten nicht der
vergangenheit angehörten sagte sachsens
innenminister schuster in der nacht zum
samstag hatten unbekannte mehrere
brandsätze gegen die hauswand geworfen
das feuer konnte rasch gelöscht werden
großer tag in sachsen anhalt für alle
erstklässler heute war ihr erster
schultag
leider starb sie unter schlechten
rahmenbedingungen und das ist seit
jahren absehbar in ganz deutschland
fielen tausende von lehrkräften in
sachsen anhalt ist das gerade besonders
heftig zu spüren annette göschel hat mir
seit sechs jahren leitet soll wickler
montanen die sekundarschule in
gardelegen lehrermangel ist ihr schon
lange ein problem doch noch nie musste
sie so viele stunden streichen wie in
diesen tagen
wir haben stunden kürzung vorgenommen in
allen klassen von beginnend kernfächern
in klasse fünf mit deutsch und englisch
bis hoch in klasse 10 dass wir ethik
religion nur noch wahrscheinlich in
einem projekt unterrichten und das zieht
sich durch alle fächer die sachsen
anhalt hat im schnitt eine
unterrichtsversorgung von 92 prozent die
gardelegener schule gerade mal 74 der
deutsche lehrerverband schätzt dass
bundesweit 25 bis 30.000 lehrer fehlen
dieses problem sei hausgemacht
einerseits hat die politik den
geburtenanstieg den wir seit über zehn
jahren haben total unterschätzt dann hat
man lehramts studienplätze abgebaut in
allen bundesländern man hat auch nicht
vorsorge getroffen auf die starke
verwaltungs welle und
pensionierungswelle die wir derzeit
haben sachsen anhalts bildungsministerin
heute bei der einschulung von
erstklässlern in halle sie verfolgt
verschiedene ideen setzt auch stark auf
seiteneinsteiger darüber hinaus haben
wir auch headhunter engagierte die also
lehrkräfte im in- und im ausland
akquirieren wir werden die
rahmenbedingungen auch etwas absenken
für die einstellungs modalitäten indem
er jetzt auch bachelor einstellen können
gardelegen bindet mit einem stipendium
frühzeitig lehramtsstudenten an die
stadt ohne dieses programm sehr es an
der sekundarschule wohl noch trauriger
aus
wer schon immer mal sehen wollte wo und
wie der bundespräsident lebt und
arbeitet der hatte heute die gelegenheit
beim tag des offenen schlosses hunderte
besucher kamen zum amtssitz von frank
walter steinmeier und wurden persönlich
von ihm begrüßt das bürgerfest wird
widmet sich in diesem jahr vor allem
jugendlichen die sich ehrenamtlich
engagieren
preise gibt es so einige in der
fernsehbranche doch der grimme-preis
ragt heraus vergeben wird er für
besondere leistungen im journalismus wie
in der unterhaltung gestern abend in mal
war es wieder so weit über die
preisverleihung thomas garcia
gleich zu beginn sagt jo schück zdf
moderator bei der verleihung habe man
auf pomp und glamour verzichtet dafür
strahlen die preisträger comedy star
anke engelke zum beispiel ausgezeichnet
mit der besonderen ehrung des
ausrichters des deutschen volkshochschul
verbands für einen humor der menschen
den spiegel vorhalte
[Applaus]
gewitzt und dann wiederum sehr ernst
zwei trophäen für diane mädel für seine
rollen in geliefert als vater in
prekären verhältnissen und auch
ard-krimi sörensen hat angst
insgesamt 19 preise gab es einmal einen
auch für die zdf journalistin katrin
eigendorf exzellent so die jury ihre
reportagen über die lage der frauen und
mädchen am hindukusch sie selbst sagt
sie versuche das zu transportieren und
nach zu fühlen was die menschen erleben
tv mit tiefgang mit anspruch der wohl
wichtigste fernsehpreis hat das wieder
gewürdigt zum 58 mal ja nur mich
preisverdächtig ist aufsteiger schalke
04 die fans in gelsenkirchen wirtschaft
wieder auf eine harte probe gestellt
statt des erhofften ersten saisonsieges
hat es für die blau-weißen profis am
vierten bundesligaspieltag eine derbe
heimniederlage gegen union berlin
gegeben 1 zu 6 hieß es am ende gegen den
hauptstadtclub der im vierten spiel zum
dritten mal gewinnt den ersten drei rot
leipzig 2 zu 0 gegen wolfsburg ebenso
leverkusen drei zu-null-siegen mainz
aber zwei platzverweise für bayern
hoffenheim gegen augsburg 1 zu 0 härter
gegen dortmund 0 1 am abend ein
klassiker die bayern gegen gladbach
natürlich ausführlich im aktuellen
sportstudio gestern freiburg gegen
bochum 102 spiele morgen union ist erst
mal tabellenführer den bayern reicht ein
punkt um das zu ändern freiburg
hoffenheim und dortmund jeweils mit dem
dritten saisonsieg die mainzer rutschen
auf platz sieben leverkusen macht
dagegen einen sprung von 17 auf 11
allerdings können stuttgart und
frankfurt morgen noch punkten härter
vorletzter bochum hat vier mal gespielt
und viermal verloren mit em gold
dekoriert kommen sprinterin gina
lückenkemper und zehnkämpfer niclas kohl
ins aktuelle sportstudio um 23 uhr
formel 1 pilot max verstappen ist der
schnellste in der qualifikation zum
großen preis von belgien carlos 1
startet allerdings von startplatz eins
denn nach motor und getriebe wechseln
muss der weltmeister fest daten wie sein
schärfster wm-konkurrent leclaire eine
strafversetzung nach hinten akzeptieren
davon profitiert auch sebastian vettel
als zehnter mit schumacher auf rang 20
die italienerin lisa wie toll sie wird
in ruhpolding sommer biathlon
weltmeisterin über sechs kilometer
denise herrmann auf rang sechs und auch
bei den männern kein deutscher auf dem
treppchen
lukas kreuzer genießt die gute stimmung
hier in ruhpolding lässt sich vom
publikum feiern platz würden für den
besten deutschen beim sprint über 7,5
kilometer nach einem fehler liegen kommt
der 28 jährige auch beim zweiten
schießen nicht fehlerfrei durch ich habe
mich stehen vor allem versucht aufstand
30 zu stellen da war es windstill hat
viermal gut geklappt beim fünften mal
leider nicht weltmeister im sprint der
schwede sebastian holtz und dahinter
sein landsmann paypal fehling bronze
geht an nicklas hardt weg aus der
schweiz
der brite adam yates gewinnt die
vorletzte etappe der deutschlandtour mit
ziel auf dem schauinsland bei freiburg
bester deutscher georg zimmermann auf
platz fünf dieser sieg ist hart erkämpft
der favoritin yates vom team movistar
gewinnt in seinem souveränen fast
mühelos ziel die bergankunft der
deutschland-tour und schnappt sich damit
das rote trikot des gesamtführenden und
es war das erwartete spektakel am berg
in teils strömendem regen von freiburg
hoch zum berg schauinsland doch der
beste deutsche georg zimmermann verliert
kurz vor dem ziel noch platz drei
diese wenig zeit wie möglich zu
verlieren um morgen ganze rundumschlag
auszuholen
es könnte morgen also eine spannende
schlussetappe werden
der ob die jetzt gesagt haben endlich
regen er aber zum schluss noch der
persönliche regenbogen aber wir haben es
gesehen es gab auch heute in einigen
regionen wieder heftige unwetter zum
beispiel in sachsen auf den straßen rund
um chemnitz herrschte gefährliches
aquaplaning in coswig bei dresden wurde
eine bahnunterführung
überflutet sie war vorübergehend nicht
mehr befahrbar
aber ab morgen soll es freundlicher
werden sagt katja horneffer die details
kommen gleich marietta slomka begrüßt
sie um viertel vor elf im heute-journal
und wir wünschen ihnen noch ein schönes
wochenende
bis morgen werden sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
nicht wahr
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt hat es ja gestern
endlich mal geregnet aber wieder nicht
überall das sehen sie hier an dem rad
afl wie die gewitter in die höhe
schossen und dann hat es eben punktuell
sehr viel regen gegeben in dem einen
stadtteil im nachbarstadtteil kam
dagegen gar nichts runter mit schauern
und gewittern haben wir es jetzt auch
noch am abend und in der nacht zu tun
vor allen dingen aber noch hier ganz im
nordosten deutschlands und auch im süden
im nordwesten dagegen lockern die wolken
auf bei nord nordwest wind und unter dem
klaren himmel wird es auch sehr frisch
da sinken die temperaturen auf 15 bis 10
grad der weil es in der schwülen luft
mit 8 10 bis 15 grad noch deutlich
milder bleibt die höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen am alpenrand und an der
nordsee bei 20 grad am main und am
oberrhein geht es auf 26 27 grad auf die
reste von schauern und gewittern
verlassen uns morgen vormittag hier
ostwärts dann wird es in norddeutschland
sehr sonnig nur im norden sind die
wolkenfelder etwas dichter in
süddeutschland sieht das anders aus doch
bis in die frühen nachmittagsstunden
drohen schauer und gewitter südlich der
donau schauer und gewitter gibt es dann
erst wieder am dienstag von südwesten
der montag aber beginnt mit dichteren
wolken im nordosten schönes wochenende